il est 8h30 ce matin quand une marée
humaine s'élance de la place anatole
france dans les rues de tours deux
concurrents prennent rapidement la tête
de la course
les éthiopiens tôt la guerre mbe dada et
toura cumby becker et ils se sont
engagés hier soir et ce sont deux
clients sérieux pour la victoire avec
son maillot rouge et bleu de l' us métro
des ulis dans l'essonne cumby bekele a
remporté le marathon de toulouse de l'an
passé les deux compatriotes ont des
records personnels autour de 2h15 il
distance donc logiquement la plupart des
coureurs qui tourne plutôt autour des
deux heures trente mais dans la campagne
tourangelle deux concurrents arrivent à
les rejoindre et accroché leur train
un peloton de 2,4 et bientôt cinq
coureurs avec bettman se forment très
provisoirement seulement car les
éthiopiens accélère et leurs rivaux ne
peuvent tenir la cadence dans le finish
c'est donc de la guimauve et dada qui
creuse l'écart sur son compatriote cumby
b quéré et s'impose donc finalement en
2h30 et 8 secondes